hey guys so i've come to a nice scenic
location today to do some training
and to talk to you about push-ups now
you might think that push-ups have
already been done to death they're all
over youtube but they are a staple of my
training and so i really wanted to talk
about them
and also i think i have some unique
perspectives and ideas to bring to the
discussion so
without further ado let's go
[Music]
[Music]
randomly one of the questions i get most
often on this
channel is should i do a hundred
push-ups a day or
what would happen if i did 200 push-ups
a day or should i do thousands of squats
a day
and this seems maybe a bit strange on
the surface why would somebody
want to do hundreds of the same exercise
when
they have enough trouble sticking to a
normal training plan but i think the
appeal of something like this is that
it's so simple
when you look at different training
programs and advice it can be really
overwhelming there's so much conflicting
advice and just
remembering all those exercises and
getting access to the equipment can be
really challenging
so many people just think it would be
easier if they could just choose one or
two exercises and
bash out tons of repetitions and of
course they're following the logic that
if a few push-ups is good
then tons of push-ups must be really
really good
but is this true the surprising answer
is yes
as long as you're also training other
parts of your body you need that
rotational strength to always talk about
all that core stability in both
directions
and in the transverse plane etc but
if you're doing those things then doing
high repetitions of body weight
exercises can be one of the very best
things
you can do for yourself in this video
i'm going to focus on push-ups why
they're so brilliant why doing high
repetitions is so brilliant
and some of the variations that you can
incorporate as well there are a few cues
to keep in mind when performing a
push-up
the first is obviously you don't want
your core to sag so you don't want your
waist
to travel towards the ground you want to
keep your body entirely nice and
straight this is obviously
also a core exercise that has the same
benefits as the plank and you won't get
those benefits if you let your
core if you let your waist droop also
just doesn't look pretty
likewise you want to make sure you
aren't flaring your elbows and this is
an interesting point because
i actually think a lot of people over
egg this point so flaring elbows looks
like this so you're in a kind of t
pose but anything below that really
75 degrees 45 degrees is fine as long as
you have more of a triangle
position than an upright position then
you're fine
so you see a lot of people trying to
correct for this because they're so hot
on flaring elbows
and as such they keep their hands here
right down by their sides that's fine if
you want to train your triceps but
it is a different exercise essentially
you can't produce as much force from
this position
if you want to go and push someone off
something you would always do it from
about here
you wouldn't naturally go into a t-pose
and you wouldn't naturally
push from here either so just do it
feels comfortable your body knows
obviously if you watch back some footage
and you think your elbows are too high
then bring them down but most people
are probably going to be fine the tip is
that at the top of the movement if you
can should try and
protract your shoulder blades that means
push them out so you're not
sagging like this and that will correct
a few other things as well it provides
additional shoulder protection
and you also want to maintain a full
range of motion so you're lowering
yourself all the way to the ground
so your chest touches the floor almost
and then you push yourself
back up but again you don't need to be
insane about this if there's about an
inch between you and the ground doesn't
mean that the
rep didn't count i mean maybe it does if
you're in some kind of competition
but in real life the research actually
is a bit contradictory and
inconclusive when it comes to how
important range of motion is if max
strength
is your main goal we know with isometric
training with overcoming isometrics so
there's about a 30
spillover so that you can train in just
one position
like this and you'll actually get
benefit here and here
just not all the way and i imagine it's
something similar here at the same time
you rarely push anything from that
position so there are varying different
results from different studies
some suggest it might even be muscle
specific
but as well as essentially allowing you
to perform more repetitions than you
otherwise
could using a more partial range of
motion might also actually contribute to
hypoxia
and metabolic stress which is some
things i'm going to talk about in a
moment and which have their
own unique benefits
you always hear all this about slow and
controlled movement you don't always
want to move slowly
and so you shouldn't always train slowly
just as there's benefit to high bar
speed when bench pressing
you can also develop your rate of force
production doing a push-up so sometimes
blasting out fast repetitions can
actually be a really useful thing and a
way to think about this is that it's
essentially becoming a more plyometric
exercise
it's like an explosive clapping push-up
except you're not actually leaving the
ground but you're getting that same
stretch shortening cycle to a degree but
you're using it more in an endurance a
strength endurance fashion
so to be clear i'm not saying you should
never perform a slow controlled
repetition of a push-up in fact that's a
very important thing you should
absolutely be doing it
but at the same time don't rule out
sometimes doing faster
slightly more bouncy push-ups for higher
rep ranges because
these have their own benefits as well
what are the benefits of doing
lots and lots of them well like i say
there's actually quite a lot
when you perform lots and lots of
repetitions of a closed chain movement
like this
what you're basically doing is you're
maintaining a constant tension
in those muscles a continuous time under
tension and what this does is it causes
the blood to pull
in that area because blood's being
brought there but the contraction is
making it harder for the blood to then
fully escape it works a little bit like
using a tourniquet and using blood flow
restriction training
and what this does is it leads to the
buildup of metabolites metabolites
include things like growth hormones that
then
trigger hypertrophy so surprisingly
doing very high repetitions
of just your own body weight can be a
good way an effective way
to build big muscle and actually i
attribute my own
pecs which are by far my strongest suit
in terms of aesthetics
to doing loads and loads of push-ups
because that's how i started training
and one way the body responds to this
kind of training is by increasing
blood flow permanently to the area
through vascularization it builds up
blood vessels capillaries that supply
the muscles
with more blood and more energy allowing
you to perform sets for longer this is
the said principle
specific adaptation to impose demands if
you want to do something better
do it more and in terms of building work
capacity the ability to exert strength
over a long period of time strength
endurance it of course doesn't get much
better than doing
high repetitions of a movement like this
because what you're essentially doing is
just testing the ability to exert
strength
for a long period of time causes all
kinds of changes not only the
vascularization
also the addition of new mitochondria
which are the energy factories of the
cells
basically means you can go harder for
longer and that increased work capacity
translates to better performance in the
gym
and better performance overall and i've
said many times on this channel
that on the whole strength endurance is
probably more important
than max strength when it comes to
general performance in life in sports
because you very rarely have to lift the
heaviest thing you can possibly lift
once more often you need to be quite
strong for a long time
and not only does this supply the
muscles with more energy thus allowing
you to go for longer it also encourages
the clearing of waste so all these
things make you better at
performing and lead to you looking
bigger and what's really cool
is that increasing vascularization
increasing blood supply to a muscle
might also increase your myonucleic
count in other words it's going to
add more nuclei to the muscles which in
turn
increases protein synthesis and your
overall potential for growth
and because myonuclei which means muscle
nuclei
don't disappear when you stop training
this also gives you bounce back
ability basically it means that you can
stop
training and whilst you might lose
muscle you'll be able to put on much
easier in future because you have those
additional my nuclei
which stick around and then allow you to
build more muscle
some of this is a little bit
hypothetical but i say it completely
gels in my own experience from me and
from people that i've trained
and it makes a lot of sense when you
kind of look between the lines
at some of the research at the same time
it might even be a useful way to
increase max strength not only because
increasing work capacity in this way
allows you to train for longer and
harder
but also because as you fatigue muscle
fibers the slow twitch muscle fibers
it's highly likely that the body is then
going to switch to the faster twitch
muscle fibers
your body only uses the most energy
efficient muscle fibers necessary for
the job
in the case of push-ups because you're
only using about 70 of your body weight
that's going to be the type
1 slow twitch muscle fiber which doesn't
equate to explosive power
when these fatigue when they run out of
juice all your body now has left is the
type 2 muscle fiber
the explosive fast twitch muscle fiber
of course it's not just going to
stop you doing the exercise if you still
have one in the tank so it's going to
switch to those
and in theory training with 100
repetitions of your
100 rep max could eventually feel a bit
like
training with one repetition of your one
rep max not the exact same
but there are definitely parallels so
you can build some strength and again
this rings true for me and for others i
know that alpha destiny talks about this
who is capable of incredible feats if
you don't have access to a bench press
then performing high high high
repetitions
of push-ups and exercises like that can
help you to maintain some strength
possibly even gain some strength and if
you look at prison workouts and military
workouts we see this repeated over and
over
people like the great gamma for instance
as well something else to remember as
well is that even max strength isn't
just about
physical changes in the muscle it's also
about building neural pathways and
improving your muscle fiber recruitment
and so by performing lots and lots of
repetitions you're practicing strength
as a skill
as pavel tatsulin would say so what do
you do if you can't do a push-up yet
you shouldn't feel bad about that a lot
of people can't perform a push-up but
that means you're the exact kind of
person
who could really benefit from doing them
ironically because this is how you'll
build that core strength
that power in the chest that can then
allow you to do all kinds of other
movements
not to mention keeping you guarded and
stronger in your everyday life so the
easier variations are of course to
perform push-ups on your knees
or to put your hands up on something
slightly higher if you can only do a few
push-ups should you just practice
five and call it a day and that's your
push-up workout done
instead consider using mechanical drop
sets so mechanical drop set means that
you're going to perform as many push-ups
as you possibly can
and then as soon as you reach failure so
you can't perform another repetition
you're going to switch to the easier
variation so you might perform
as many push-ups as you can say that's
five then you're gonna perform push-ups
on your knees with no
rest in between and then once you've
done those you might even start doing
some wall push-ups this means that you
can fatigue all of those muscle fibers
you can use proper form at the beginning
but at the same time you're still
building those neural pathways still
flooding the area with blood and causing
muscle damage etc which is hard to do
when you can only perform
a couple of repetitions
i'm gonna go somewhere now where the
floor isn't covered in sharp pieces of
wood
why did i choose this is the spot to
film about plyometric push-ups
i don't know but it toughens up the
hands
for those of you who are looking for
some variations that are perhaps a
little bit more difficult
i run through a bunch here so often this
is going to involve
changing the lever arm or moving just
onto one hand
one of the most obvious ways to perform
a more difficult push-up
is to do a one-handed push-up like so
this is awesome not only because you now
have to basically
lift twice the amount of weight because
you've only got one arm but also because
you now have to resist
rotation because you're missing one of
your supports your body wants to twist
towards the ground and you have to brace
the core on the transverse plane
to prevent that from happening another
one that's really good is the archer
push-up where you move from one arm to
another whilst keeping your other hand
on the ground
this adds a nice stretch onto the pecs
which may even encourage
muscle damage in the positive sense and
therefore hypertrophy
and again it's a great way to build up
towards the one arm to push up
i like to sometimes just stay on one
side over
one half of my body and support myself
gently with the other hand and you can
call this
an assisted one-armed push-up or you
could call it a
rocking push-up i sometimes use that and
that basically
looks like this
if you want to get a really good pump
going in the pecs then performing these
assisted one-arm push-ups is a really
great way to do that
especially because you can provide more
resistance with that arm as you start to
fatigue on that side
thereby turning this into a more
conventional drop set
and yeah this is what i'm talking about
so you might perform as many
one-armed push-ups as you can once you
reach failure
switch to an assisted one-armed push-up
help yourself less and less
do the same on the other side and
immediately switch to regular push-ups
now i've got grass going in my face and
this is going to give you
a huge pump and builds tons of strength
endurance and it just
adds variety to your training as well
and something else you can do is
actually just vary the cadence and the
tempo within a single set so
you might perform a few really slow
controlled push-ups and then switch
immediately to fast and explosive
push-ups
and thereby you're essentially targeting
both types of twitch muscle fiber
and at the same time just extending that
set
even longer this builds a massive pump
and it'll build both that kind of
slow controlled strength finesse and
that explosive
and high repetition strength endurance
at the other end of the spectrum in fact
if you want to go really slow and
controlled you can try performing what's
called a
quasi-isometric push-up here you're
going to perform the movement as slowly
slowly as you possibly can
so it might take you a whole minute or
perhaps even longer or maybe just 30
seconds to begin with
what you're doing here is you're
exerting just the necessary strength
to hold yourself at that particular
position you're making sure that there's
no momentum to help you through the
range of motion there's no strength
curve
you're just controlling every single bit
of that movement and you can perform
this in a
passive manner which means that you
relax any muscles that aren't directly
involved or you can do it in a more
active manner where you're
tensing the whole body throughout the
movement either way the passive
option can help to build more efficiency
whereas the active version is a more
intense
workout and you're plugging those
kinetic leaks and of course we can't
talk about
more explosive push-ups without
discussing or explosive push-ups
clapping push-ups
and what have you these are essentially
a plyometric form of push-up where
you're launching yourself up in the end
you do all sorts of things around the
world where you
spin around and land back on your hands
or clap behind your back or clap three
times or
throw your arms and legs up in the air
get your whole body off the ground keep
in mind though that none of this is
necessary that's going to create a lot
of impact on your wrists and
it can actually take the focus away from
the movement itself
all you really need to be doing and this
tip i think came from varva fitness
is just pushing yourself off the ground
and if you make it so that each rep is a
launch so that you're not pausing and
bobbing in between but just launching
straight back up
then you're turning it into a form of
shock training which basically means
you're using the myotastic stretch
response to immediately return that
energy and this can build
a lot of explosiveness i said clapping
your hands and spinning around things
like that can be a lot of fun and it's a
great way to
test yourself and check your progress of
course there's many
many more push-up variations there's
things like the pseudo-planche push-up
which is great for building straight arm
strength and
more core control and obviously a great
progression for planche itself
there's pike push-ups which are a more
vertical version
and these are all great but these are
different exercises essentially that
target different muscle groups and
perhaps i'll do a list of push-up
variations in future but
but for now i wanted to talk more about
how to integrate those variations
and why you should rather than the
variations yourself so
yeah using these mechanical drop sets is
not only a great way to
train everything to go past fatigue and
to test yourself whatever level you're
at
but it's also a fantastic way to get
variety in your training and to mix it
up so you're getting more benefits
so yeah just vary up and mix it up
mechanical drop sets is one way of doing
it
or you can just do what i really like to
do as well which is just to
completely mix up the order and turn it
into a kind of
improv which is fun it keeps you
actively focused on the workout and it
can offer
tons of benefits i hope you found this
video useful and interesting guys if you
did then please leave a like and share
around that would help me out
immensely i'd greatly appreciate it
likewise comment down below and let me
know your favorite push-up variation
that'll be really cool actually i'd love
to hear some of yours i get so many
ideas
for videos from your comments and so i
massively appreciate that too i love
talking with you guys
um subscribe if you want more like this
hit the bell button if you want
notifications every time i upload a new
video
if you want an introduction to
functional training and how to train so
that it improves your sports and your
life then
check out my book functional training
and beyond available from amazon and
from bookstores there'll be a link in
the description
if you want a ebook and training program
then check out super functional training
that's the book that discusses how to
train your body and your mind and your
mobility all at the same
time and has a program at the end as
well as some freebies
that's on discount right now during the
pandemic so check out the link in
description below for that one too
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now